we're choice well I guess it did come
out 20 years ago this summer good enough
for me you know their names you know
their faces and when the two of them
switch you know they're gonna get off
face off one cop will do whatever it
takes to take down the man who killed
his son by cutting his rivals face off
putting that face on his own face doing
absolutely nothing to change his body
healing instantly from this massive
surgery telling no-one what he did going
undercover in a prison where everyone
wears magnet boots gaining the trust of
his Muffit voice brother I'm getting
high and maybe porking his rivals
girlfriend all the while hoping his
rival doesn't wake from a coma put his
face on his body
pork his wife with his face kill his
boss and challenge him to a deadly
speedboat fight forcing him to harpoon
him with a spear gun and adopt his love
child to replace the similar-looking son
he killed five years ago it all makes
perfect sense if you're on a lot of
cocaine prepare for the matchup you
didn't know you were waiting for John
Travolta versus Nicolas Cage to
oscar-worthy actors who turned into
jokes made the effort and become
oscar-worthy again then realize it's way
more fun to be ridiculous in this script
that makes slightly more sense when you
find out it was written for
Schwarzenegger and Stallone oh man that
would have been awesome but at least we
got escape plan
[Music]
if you love action director John Woo has
something for you
as woo-woos you with his signature DS
dives dual-wielding
and doves so many doves as you enjoy
action set-pieces
that never stop until they stop to point
their guns at each other
dramatically hope we don't have in
common
shoot is that I don't care if I live and
you do and shoot that hurts shoot now
now shoot shoot and shoot shoot dammit
shoot each other in your faces witness
the over-the-top craziness of two actors
playing other actors pretending to be
themselves I think where Nick Cage acts
like John Travolta learning to act like
Nic Cage while John Travolta acts like
Nic Cage slowly realizing how boring it
is to be John Travolta
is turning into real marriage confused
don't worry so is everyone else so if
you love body swap comedies like Freaky
Friday but wish everyone was trying to
kill each other then faceoff is the only
movie crazy enough from 96 to 97 for you
except maybe Conair or the rock wow what
a crazy couple of years for action
movies huh and by action movies I mean
the cage
no more drugs for that man starring look
who's talking
despite on my rage I am still just
Nicolas Cage emo Philips I used to love
doggy Chow The Bourne Supremacy Margaret
Cho that's weird the director of The
Notebook
that's even weirder peach appreciation
my peach you know I cannot eat a page
for hours
your little peach sushi right remember
me I'm your favorite piece each peaches
and Travolta's weird face touching habit
but darling my beautiful my wickedly
talented idina menzel trading faces you
know we've been living together as man
and wife for a week how does she not
know it was her husband's face on a new
body did they switch dongs too cuz dong
off is a very different movie if my
voice were any juicier it would be a
peach hey lady
with an epic voice comes epic
responsibility you make 100 percent of
the shots you don't miss I ate the
Dorito diamond